in our conversations one of the things
that I liked about what you did and um
which is what I do is you get very clear
on the specs and you ra you know that
people are
different and you make very clear
distinctions of what somebody is like
you know and and and we try to do the
same thing what it's like but you're
really talking not just about skills
you're talking about things like um
consideration
determination and you were talking we
were talking about about um toughness
okay and all the different types of
toughness and you'll Speck it out I know
for me I try to Speck it out same thing
try to Speck it out so I know in detail
because if you know what somebody's like
you know how they're going to perform in
a job right right and and there's some
things you can change or improve whether
it be experience or technique or um you
know sometimes just maturity and and um
and then there are other things that are
I think fundamentally very hard to
change um so you have to live with those
height for example uh so some things you
get and then there's other things that
you look at and say okay you know we can
adjust this but ultimately if a player
uh or a coach you know whoever you bring
to your organization has something that
you feel like you are going to have to
manage to a certain degree then you have
to ask yourself are we capable of that
can we give the person what they need do
we have the resources to help them with
whatever it is that they need so that
they can be successful and if the answer
is no then I think you just have to be
realistic and say okay well then you
know we're just this isn't the right fit
we need to move on and find somebody
else um and that's not always the
easiest thing to identify but when you
can identify what the problem is is uh
whether it be physical or you know some
other some other form that whether or
not you you have the resources
organizationally you know to handle
that